christopher hill est passé dans
l'émission l'année dernière mais il a
très mal vécu l'expérience dépression
perte de poids il s'est même laissé
pousser là bas pour qu'on ne le
reconnaisse plus
bas et c'était cet art us en fait le
terrain on regarde son portrait il nous
expliquera pourquoi il est pas bien
christophers et voilà ça fait partie de
ce que vous disiez valérie benaïm
pourtant moi je suis fou de cette
émission après voilà c'est vrai que 6
épisodes noirs ne force personne la m6 a
participé mais les retirer la société de
la décadence absolue violence merci
regardez
maintenant presqu'un an quand on parle
avec analyse qu'on a une relation
sexuelle et on a tout de suite eu
nourris à chimie entre nous deux on
délire beaucoup sur les chansons moi
j'aime bien j'aime la chanter j'aimerais
que ce soit l'amour de ma vie mais j'ai
rien osé dire parce que j'ai peur de la
perdre et eux est là on voit quelqu'un
elle m'a déjà raconté sa vie
sentimentale ou trois mois de relation
entre les garçons elle est tout de suite
venu m'annoncer que valve était enceinte
anaïs a choisi de garder l'enfant
pourrait assurer sur la plus totale
l'idée serait de lui déclarer ma flamme
en musique j'ai repris une petite
chanson que j'ai écrite moi même et j'ai
hâte de lui faire écouter la chanson
alors regardez ils sont avec nous
christopher et anaïs merci d'être avec
nous
vous avez eu un an de relation virtuelle
on va en parler dans un instant on va
savoir où vous en êtes tous les deux en
tout cas vous avez très bien ensemble je
ne sais pas si vous êtes cet ensemble on
va le savoir dans un instant mais je
trouve que forment un beau couple et je
sais que j'ai l'oeil pour les couples
c'est moi qui ai conseillé castaldi cinq
fois christopher a fait l'expérience il
était avec anaïs déjà la question que
tout le monde se pose christopher
pourquoi vous regrettez d'avoir
participé à l'émission je regrette
d'avoir participé à l'émission parce que
clairement samassa mali me traumatiser
j'ai très mal vécu par rapport à deux
fois déjà par rapport à l'image qu'on
m'a donné parce que on on a fait mettre
râteau à la télé alors que ce n'était
pas ça qui était prévu en fait en fait
embarquer quoi en fait qu'éprouvez vous
prévoyez des trucs avant dans ses passes
a en fait accordé en fait ma copine qui
aux côtés anaïs mana un an j'ai
donc été avec moi à l'émission et
pendant que j'entends j'attendais à eau
dans la chambre en bas elle s'est fait
remonter la tête
van damme quel camp au moment où il est
monté en haut dans la chambre il ya une
dame qui venait me voir et qui manager
ça se voit que t'es pas intéressé ouais
du coup apple je suis dit non et moi
j'étais enceinte à ce moment là donc
beaucoup moi je voulais pas lui tenir
oui j'étais enceinte mais de
personne
à personne au bon sens et j'étais
enceinte et je voulais ni dire oui ni
dire non parce que j'étais enceinte mais
vous étiez plus avec la personne et non
juste en seraient pas d'accord c'est ça
voilà voilà et je voulais ni milité au
courant crise et accord n'est pas de
dire oui je voulais pas dire non parce
que j'ai à dire c'est que je reste en
stand by voilà ce que j'attendais
d'accoucher bien sûr chose que je pense
normal pour une fête géante à fait
normal et en berne dame qui est venu et
qui m'a dit écoute
ça se voit que t'es pas intéressés dont
cappelleri jean où j'y mets moi je peux
pas l'appeler lui dire non comme ça je
suis pas je pars donc fait comme ça il
m'a avoué ses sentiments et c'est pas
cool pour lui que nation et du coup j'ai
demandé à monter quand même et elle m'a
dit oui mais tu peux pas dire peut-être
je dis oui ou non donc j'ai mon choix a
tranché vers le nom parce que je voulais
pas me donner cette image de lavéra tout
à fait madame après la production sans
vouloir les défendre ils peuvent se dire
aussi qu'ils veulent pas forcer les gens
à aller dans la chambre et s'est donc
ils sont ni il sentait pas que tu
voulais y aller ils sont ni peut-être
qu'il faut aller la voir parce que lé
voilà on voit qu'elle is it et si l is
it c'est que c'est plutôt non on préfère
voilà que qu'elle aille et ici il n'y
avait pas de t'être tous les tenants et
les aboutissants de la sphère donc toi
ça christophe christopher c'est insulter
ni je me suis pris avant en direct c'est
à la télé il sent que c'est ça qu'il ya
quoi d'autre quitte à céder retombée
après on fait des missions voilà parce
que quand on est une personne un peu
forte à la télé tu peux pas savoir à 6,6
grosses berlines ont pour la télé je
suis désolé pour l'apd aidez moi mon
image je pense qu'on est tous d'accord
et non à la télé quand on est gros noms
mais je te laisse
te dis alors là moi je te jure
christopher ici moi je ne trouve pas
question je suis désolé pour les grands
il
s'était menaces de mort des six derniers
y avait quand même des choses totor des
gros porcs na nana na na mais si tu
commences à écouter les abrutis se
traite sur rue merry sociaux mais 57
personnes forcées de
discuter franchement je trouve très beau
gosse christopher merci mais maintenant
je me suis un peu amélioré qua non mais
non mais je te dis ouais non mais
attendez moi je vous dis par rapport au
passage je sais que l'émission quand on
m'a contacté parce que c'est même pas
moi qui voulais la faire on m'a contacté
on m'a dit c'est une émission hyper
bienveillante il savait que j'avais des
problèmes par rapport au poids et tout
est mis et m'ont fait mon image a
clairement été mais ce que c'est de leur
faute parce que c'est comment les
réseaux sociaux surtout c'est pas de la
faute de la production non mais t'as
écouté pour moi je trouve que c'est 50
50 ans soit 50 50 parce que moi par la
suite on n'a même pas appelé pour savoir
si j'allais bien s'il était vivant
quand même après c'est vrai que c'est
parce qu'on reçoit plein de haine pleine
de menaces instillant sort dans la rue
on te dit gros porc ou alors par exemple
tu t'es pris un râteau dans la gueule
fois par honte et 6 me mais au final
commande qu'on voulait au final y'a pas
de psy afin de s'y met alors après on a
plus de souci
[Musique]
je me
moque est habitué aux réseaux sociaux
comme sa fille d'avoir l'habitude les
insultes on est tous insulté ses réseaux
sociaux
j'ai pas des rues besoins des réseaux
sociaux pourtant sultan
bernard tu vas pas normaliser le fait
qu'ils se faire un nom non je normal
surtout pas heureux en train de dire on
est une horreur on est comme ça des
alliés comme ça fait des années qu'ils
dessus malheureusement
la population berbère est important vous
êtes allé à l'émission et donc vous avez
décidé de passer à la télé mais vous
n'avez jamais imaginé qu'il pouvait y
avoir des répercussions que je condamne
en vie mais vous savez ce que c'est la
télé c'est une sorte de miroir délire on
n'est pas imaginer je vous aimerai t non
parce que on m'a clairement dit que ça
allait être une émission où ils voient
que du bon qu'il n'y aura pas de mauvais
par la suite on a choisi mes vêtements
aussi pour quand c'est juste à la télé
donc ça ne m'était pas forcément en
valeur ce que je n'ai pas apprécié non
plus et voilà il ya plein de choses qui
font d'abord affaire qui été forcé au
ciad voilà j'étais blonde de base on m'a
fait changer de couleur de sous alors
juste que j'ai fait avec lui moi ça n'a
pas marché valeur ce qui m'intrigue
c'est que tu dis que tu voulais pas
faire ses missions a et qui tombent pas
directement là bas ils voulaient la
faire
tomber sur la grâce de la télé star ils
viennent chercher des gens sur les
toits j'aime chercher plutôt aller
chercher daniel moment là
alors anaïs et qu'elle soffer la
question qu'on se pose est ce que vous
vous êtes ensemble aujourd'hui ou est ce
que maintenant vous êtes chacun de votre
côté et les moutons seront bien gardées
ouais l'a redit de répondre
à tout mettre au foot on est restés en
très bons termes donc on a toujours les
mêmes ceux là je suis un peu compliqué
parce qu'il m'en voulait à moi de
l'avoir mis un vent fort ça bien sûr
après on s'est expliqué christopher toi
c'était à nice tu as vu un crush pour
elle vraiment
on était prêt à assumer mon enfant et
touba oui alors bah oui analystes parce
que cet ami c'était amical j'ai du temps
ensemble je venais de me séparer après
maintenant parce que l'on fondé
il est né il a eu un oui alors elle a
quel âge un arrière d'accord il
s'appelait comment cléophée cléophée et
donc soit vous vous en êtes où vous êtes
ben là le c'est compliqué parce qu'il
travaille beaucoup il a vite - moi j'ai
mon bébé donc oui si on se voit pas
forcément avec qui pas d'accord
monaco est donc vous n'êtes pas du tout
ensemble non aimé par contre ça peut
arriver un jour justement la ja le
baptême de ma fille et prochainement il
va rencontrer toute ma famille donc
pouvoir peut-être vous êtes dépassés à
marier au premier regard
non mais c'est donc c'est pas ça non
marié s'est pas complètement mort j'aime
bien il faut le faire à l'abri des
caméras
soit il a pas alors simon aller
tranquille si vous l'êtes tranquille
cette pluie si
non mais non mais c'est vrai que j'aime
bien que les chauffeurs ouais parce que
je sens qu anaïs est l t'aime bien mais
sans que les sens qu'elle se dit c'est
un gars sur qui je peux compter et c'est
vrai que c'est un gars de confiance c
était moi je trouve très séduisant être
est ce que vous avez très bien ensemble
et je pense que ce serait bête de passer
à côté d'une histoire d'un conseil
énormément de gens qui sont passés à
côté d'une histoire d'amour je ne dis
pas ça que pour raymond
non mais c'est vrai mais manque à lyon
il est passé à côté et je sens quand
même qu'il ya un petit truc et anaïs je
sens que termine à christopher mais tu
te dis voilà ce que je saute le pas ou
pas
ces cantiques et ce qu'on peut t'aider
parfois l'amitié se transforme en amour
peut-être regarde benhaim
pivot cyril c'est que malgré
l'humiliation malgré le fait que vous
ayez mal vécu cette émission vous êtes
tous les deux la côte à côte et je
trouve qu'il a beaucoup de bienveillance
à vous regarder tout ça c'est quand même
parce que noir c'était vraiment sincère
quand je vois la saison de la savoie en
fait ouais y'a que des fakes
rien que des fake vous accueillez vous
cette essence et 1
était la meilleure méthode d'avouer ses
sentiments à la tête je pense qu'elle
n'assurait ce que vous auriez pas
préféré puis peut-être un amour secret
obligé de se cacher un secret pas le
droit de le dire
maintenant bah oui en tout cas moi je
vous souhaite beaucoup de bonheur et je
sens que ça peut aboutir cette affaire
on dit je connais l'amour
oui oui mais d'amour oui je connais
l'amour peut être freinée
c'était dans la zone des amies s'arroge
alors c'est la joie combien de meuf
m'ont fait croire qu'elle voulait qu'on
soit en prennent bonne et qui ont voulu
me pécho après alors ça marchait pas du
tout je reste en france
[Applaudissements]